This video is brought to you by keeps
What's up. Wisecrack Michael, here,
I have a confession to make about the team here at wisecrack.
We're obsessed with cults, documentaries about cults even more.
So now to be clear, we have no interest in joining one,
as they are usually very bad and caused lots of psychological and often physical
harm to people.
So it's probably no surprise that we've been mainlining episodes of the vow,
the recent series,
exploring a cult called Nexium and it's judo champion at 11 figurehead,
Keith Ranieri,
who sucks and was just sentenced to 120 years behind bars for some truly
horrific crimes for the uninitiated.
Nexium is one part in multi-level marketing scheme,
where you pay thousands of dollars to the leadership classes in hotel conference
rooms, and five parts, a cult where people were different colored sashes,
and sometimes branded themselves with Keith Raniere, his initials,
before sleeping with them.
Now this all grabbed my attention because people like to call her nary a
philosopher.
I have as my mentor and American scientist and philosopher by the name of Keith
Ranieri.
And according to the university that gave me a PhD in the people who published
my book. I am too no judo skills though.
I was pretty good at volleyball in high school.
So join me as I suspended my critical judgment and see what this smartest man
alive has to say. And maybe in the process,
we can figure out how a great big creep convinced everyone to mutilate
themselves for the love of knowledge. Let's go.
And before we get into it, I want to give a shout out to keeps.
I personally love my style. I love my hat collection and my sneakers.
Some people love to do their makeup or support their Supreme trim.
Others love styling their hair. And if that's you,
then I can totally see why losing your hair might seem like the end of the
world. I wouldn't panic though, because you can combat hair loss.
And the sooner you take action,
the more hair you can keep keeps is an affordable hair loss treatment plan that
brings FDA approved prescriptions and over the counter medication,
right to your door. It's so simple and easy.
You can complete all the steps online from the comfort of your own home.
You'll visit a virtual doctor and the medication will be shipped straight to
you.
If you're noticing that you're losing hair and aren't ready to rock the bald,
look, then check out,
keeps today with keeps some men even experienced hair regrowth.
So give it a go for a limited time,
go to keeps.com/wisecrack or click the link in the description to receive
50% off your first order. Now back to the show.
There's no problem with the planet it's been stuck. We do,
you will be as ethical as possible.
You will be that which you want to see in the world.
Oh, says the grown man in the white sash.
So this sounds straightforward enough if a little vague,
the thing that comes up again and again,
is that [inaudible] has this cool new form of ethics.
And it's going to transform the world. Many of his followers refer to him as,
I guess she made a turn I've ever met, but superly gives the side.
What does that even mean? Luckily, philosophers love defining terms.
Most broadly,
ethics defines good and bad behavior for the ancient Greeks like Plato or
Aristotle.
This meant living a virtuous life through your more modern utilitarian theorist.
It's the idea that we should take actions that will bring the most amount of
happiness to the most amount of people.
Another big player deontology argues that any good act must be
applied universally. There is no exceptions, like a line is bad,
except for when I'm lying to save a loved one from a murderer.
And of course there's someone like novelist, iron Rand,
who thought the pursuit of one's individual happiness was the only truly ethical
position.
A lot of it is the philosophy of objectivism, which is Iran.
There it is Ranieri shares. Rand's individualist vision for the world,
but I don't think reading the Fountainhead makes you the CEO of ethics anymore
than reading the old man.
And the sea qualifies you to join the cast of deadliest catch.
We should be building ethicists.
People are going to elect ethicists to be present.
Now,
if we're going for people who pursue their own happiness should run society.
Well,
this basically already exists in the form of every venture capitalist and Karen
at a Starbucks. Also, if we're going for a plagiarized iron Rand,
there's plenty of people in elected office who already espouse her views.
So not much to see here.
An act of character,
you feel all those emotions and there's a part of you that is unflappable.
Absolutely committed.
Okay. Finally, getting a little more specific. Now this isn't a brand new idea.
For example, philosopher,
Emmanuel Kant thought any real ethical act had to be disconnected from emotions.
So it's not about feeling like something is the right thing to do.
It's about knowing something is the right thing to do,
even if you absolutely do not feel like doing it. And to an extent,
this seems to be what Ranieri is getting at.
But the crucial difference is that for current,
these ethical acts have to be grounded in the principle of humanity,
meaning that we never use human beings as fodder for some bigger goal.
So a we're still saying it's a no-go on sexually.
What civilization people working together based on principle to
improve the nature of existence itself.
It's the worst summer camp ever, but there's nothing too controversial here.
Sigmund Freud,
the guy who made you feel creepy for loving your mother might say that
civilization helps us shove our instinctual desires into a deep pit.
So we can make this society loving part of our brain happy.
And other philosophers like John jock were so thought that the nature of human
civilization was putting the strengths of individuals together to collectively
achieve greater things.
So near his definition is both uncontroversial and kind of boring. All right,
what's next?
There's that definition of how it's come to life, which is,
I thought you knew
the definition of hell is you on the day that you're going to die,
how you are meeting that you, you could have been.
That's a really good one.
They say philosophy begins in condescension,
but unlike handing out colorful sashes to your underlings,
this is actually a cool idea.
It's also something most first-year philosophy students would recognize as not
very original Friedrich Nietzsche, who didn't even know what volleyball was.
Describe something like this as a love of fate.
Basically he imagined living your life on repeat Groundhog day style to the end
of eternity. If that sounds like a bummer,
you're probably not stoked on your life choices or on the prospect of repeating
them forever. But if you truly embrace your life and your actions,
you might be stoked to do it all over again. And again, and again,
we're narrows ideas, just a rhetorical twist instead of pondering,
whether you're going to suffer eternally as you relive your choices,
you instead just get to meet the person who made the best version of themselves.
So I mean sure, but both bill Murray and Nisha said it better.
Moving on.
It is true for you. So therefore it is true to some degree
for me.
This looks like he's really getting into the philosophy of why you never,
never questioned me.
And it's interesting as coronary is varying into the territory of what we call
post-modernism or perspectivism these theorists argue that there is no such
thing as fixed or objective truth,
but the truth is dependent on our experience and perspective and that different
individuals could have different experiences of the same events.
This idea has been explored by Nicha Jacques Derrida,
and Jean-Francois leotard to advocate that we be skeptical about just how
amazing and all-knowing human beings can actually be people in this camp to
varying degrees,
argue that there is no one objective truth that transcends culture,
context or perspective,
but this doesn't mean whatever is true for me is my truth. You dig instead,
it means that we need to be humble enough to acknowledge that different people
will have different perspectives and views with their own biases,
even when experiencing the same event, text or discount buffet, of course,
for context here and Neri is using this idea to Gaslight a group of women
carefully expressing their concerns about his behavior.
And that's absolutely not cool.
So views is a made up human construct.
And a lot of times the screaming of abuse is abuse in itself.
So we can just say it now, right? This guys is just a piece of,
I think we can just say it. You guys see it. I see it. We can switch and say,
okay,
so what is doing here is playing Madlibs with postmodern language for
philosophers like Derrida postmodernism was a way to rethink how certain we can
really be about human knowledge.
It was not a way to tell people they were wrong for feeling abused or
victimized.
Ranieri is peddling in exactly the type of that postmodernism has been
criticized for by those who frankly, didn't read the books.
So what else does judo man have for us?
Primitive parts of us are hungry. Beasties. I mean,
that's what we want to do. Oh, okay. Um.
I almost don't want to give this idea at the time of day,
but he seems to be veering into the realm of someone like Thomas Hobbes,
who thought the human state of nature is one of all out war where we do whatever
we can to eat, screw and survive. However,
philosophers ranging from Plato to Aristotle, to cot, to contemporary figures,
like a long bed Jews have argued that to think of ourselves as crass animals is
to miss what makes humans interesting, namely our capacity for reason,
and our ability to seek truth Khan says that if we were just meant to eat,
sleep and screw the nature,
did a job at designing us because we're also neurotic and curious,
and anxious and reflective all things that don't really help our animals
survival, even primatologists who studied the behavior of primates,
gorillas and stuff reject the idea that primates are just murderous,
violent freaks.
There's plenty of evidence that our thumbless cousins also work together and to
have hot consensual relations.
So current actual scientists and many others would say that refineries over
identification of humans with primitive Beasties is woefully inadequate.
It also creates a dangerous paradigm in which people can do really bad things
and justify it because they're just hungry Beasties. Okay.
We're almost done, but we have one more gem to consider.
Okay.
I wrote a fable once that started that there was a mighty King
that took over a culture. Wow.
Dude wrote a fable.
And this King used torture and fear to create a BDO
once.
Sounds kind of like a co-leader who collects blackmail on his followers.
And over time,
people found that if they just abate what the King said,
there was peace across the land.
But what they sacrificed for that was their traditions, their customs,
and all of their identity.
The threat of violence was enough to keep social order.
But if the King went and killed everyone,
then he would have to do all the work.
So the people who are being victimized have a certain
power and they can stand against the King.
Okay. Um, where to begin with this one, um, first of all,
he didn't write a fable once he's as much ASAP as he is not a sociopath.
The basic gist here is powerful. People use that power to the Lord over others,
but they often need the powerless to maintain their own power,
not in original or new, of course, special or interesting idea,
but philosophically it's a watered down version of Hegel's master,
slave dialectic,
which is a fable that explains the structure of human consciousness and also
everything else for Hagle,
the master Lords over his slaves to feel powerful and their recognition of him
as the master confirms this feeling.
But eventually the slaves realized that they actually do a lot more than their
master and that without them he's basically useless.
And the master realizes that he's actually dependent on them to feel all
powerful and special. So voila, we had a reversal of power now for Hagle.
This explains a concept called mutual recognition where both sides realize
they're neutral interdependence for scenario. This means that, um,
if everyone in his cult locked out, he'd be left powerless, but they haven't.
So everything's chill. Okay.
So what have we learned by suspending our judgment to momentarily consider the
philosophy of a real life piece of? Well,
[inaudible] modus operandi seems pretty simple. Step one,
take some relatively basic uncontroversial ideas. Step two,
rephrase them to make yourself sound smart and original and step three,
use these original ideas to justify your sadistic and manipulative agenda and
convince your followers to do stuff like separate ties with their loved ones and
enter into master slave relationships with their friends,
interrogating the tradition for insights and how to live a good and virtuous
life. This is not well,
that's it for our philosophical journey into the mind of a sociopathic cult
leader.
And hopefully this is a good reminder that if someone is trying to get you to
pay lots of money, to join their philosophical movement,
you should run as fast as you can in the opposite direction and never look back
seriously.
If a philosophical education is what you seek simply visit your local library.
We mentioned books all the time in our videos,
so go check them out and please let us know what you think of this new format in
the comments. We just wanted to try something fun,
which is something we all need these days. Right? Huge.
Thanks to our patrons for your support hit that subscribe button.
Like it's the lever that keeps your train from going anywhere near Albany and as
always, thanks for watching.
Later,
[inaudible].